[Musik]
schließlich gibt es ein richtig tolles
rezept was hier aussieht wie ein wilder
kräutergarten wird gleich eine leckere
kräuterlimonade gibt keine kräuterbutter
von kräuterlimonade
der borat reist die schweizer
beachvolleyballer gibt ja und almdudler
richtig kugeln fridolfing genauso
schmeckt lecker und da sind also das hat
ein seminarist sich super mit dabei
wir werden heute keinen zucker nehmen
sondern apfelsaft er hat praktisch von
natur aus zucker ich weiß was du magst
immer gerne fühlt ich denke dass wir mit
dem apfelsaft auch ganz gut hinkommen
und dann kann einfach jeder selbst
entscheiden wie süße limonade machen
möchte ich habe jetzt hier kräuter aus
dem garten genommen falls ihr es keinen
kräutergarten habt müsst ihr einfach im
supermarkt holen diese kräuter behälter
und dann könnte eben auch die kräuter
echt gut verwenden
mit dem riesen strauch zitronenmelisse
und den rest werden wir ein volles
risiko gehen früh schon richtig gut
sollte mal und rechtlich werde ich weiß
wo abnutzen und trocknen lassen genau
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten
bestehe nämlich hier vorne
ich habe jetzt 14 teils frischem in zehn
teile zitronenmelisse eine zitrone davon
brauche ich den saft sehen teil aber
wenig um und fünf teile rosmarin und
hier habe ich noch einen liter apfelsaft
morath und es geht auch super einfach
mit ja genau so überragend meinte ist ja
schon mal mit dabei und die kräuter die
nehmen wir jetzt einfach einmal habe ich
mal vom barkeeper gelernt einfach hier
rein
sie können dann noch ein bisserl
abschöpfen einfach alles mit rheines
weder später aufgekocht auch verstehen
und alle machen jetzt alles rein später
wieder ab die habe ich noch aufpassen
als auch egal wenn die käfer ausmacht
ist es egal wie komplex immer die kraft
vor allem im buch gehen
ganz frisch abgezockt und wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie so ein kräuterbeet
funktionieren video schon gemacht
hochbeet geht einmal 110 die hochbeete
sich einen eigenen kräutergarten
bereichen banken oder freaks richtig
sorgen sind wandel und rosmarin und im
prinzip können sie auch gerne noch
andere kräuter verwenden aber ich finde
die halt wirklich perfekt so jetzt mit
dem abgesagt auftreten wie von hexen
kräutermischung informiert war wäre
jetzt erst mal gefragt kommt zwar mehr
wir machen weiter im heck gezaubert war
eine große zitronen deswegen habe ich
die orange kurz zu spüren
jetzt lasse ich die mischung aufkochen
und stellt dann den herd wieder ab das
heißt einmal kurz aufkochen lassen denn
hat wieder ausschalten und dann las ich
die mischung 30 minuten mit
geschlossenen becken zufrieden und so
entfalten sich dann einfach schön alle
aromen und dann geht's wieder weiter
angespannt vielleicht wird es in
marktlücke von schneider machen reine
verlieh kräuterlimonade wahrscheinlich
ohne zuckerzusatz
[Musik]
weiter durch mit richtig toll durch
sehen jetzt sehr abschließen
gefeiert wird hier ein kleines geschenk
durchdrücken und dann lasse ich nicht
reden sagt also diese saft
kräutermischung gut abkühlen und dann
beim künftig auch schon fertig damit
später noch auf getroffen werden
durch drücken kann mit dem letzten satz
auch noch auch gekommen
[Musik]
das kann ich jetzt so abdecken in den
kühlschrank stellen
und wenn es komplett kaltes essen das
probiert jetzt ist die kräuter in
moscheen abgekühlt und das ist ja auch
ein konzentrat hier mit dirigent
getränke bringen da finde ich ganz
praktisch und vor allem richtig schön
ich habe hier noch mal die ganzen
kräuter das ist er dort deko du sagst
die müsste jetzt nicht mit rein geben
aber ich find's ganz schön
die gebe ich jetzt hier unten mit in den
spender dameneinzel obendrauf
ihr müsst jetzt so machen das konzentrat
ist ein drittel und dann kommen noch mal
zwei drittel wasser für zws liste sein
ich mache es ein drittel übernahm ein
drittel ein schlüssel und ein drittel
vom wasser selbst von allem einliefern
[Musik]
zu deko zwecken kommen jetzt noch
zitronenscheiben deko und
forschungszwecken
jetzt geht es dir monat drauf
[Musik]
und für den besonderen kick natürlich
noch ein strich die mineralwasser
[Musik]
mit keine ski vorne zu schließen und
dann kann sich jeder der eine
erforschung braucht einfach hier
bedienen und nur sagen die limonade
richtung richtig lecker und jetzt hoffen
[Musik]
ich habe mal kurz durch gerührt und
jetzt kann ich das tun
[Musik]
richtig lecker lecker und vor allem ohne
zugesetzten zucker wenn wir nur die süße
vom apfelsaft des super erfrischend
jetzt habe ich schon so viele tolle
getränke rezepte gemacht und habe immer
gesagt das ist mein lieblingsrezept aber
heute ist dieses jahr mein liebster
fischen durch die minze durch die
zitronenmelisse solltet ihr auf jeden
fall mal nachmachen und am besten macht
ihr gleich das doppelte rezession zu
führen fall
[Musik]
ich hätte auch zu trinken da nicht
gleich die ganze karosserie euch
wirklich viel spaß beim nachmachen falls
ihr das rezept noch einmal nachlesen
möchte geht auffällig wenn der etat
steht noch mal alles ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen und eine gute erforschung und
bis zum nächsten mal schön
[Musik]
mit